[Music]
robert joins us in albuquerque new
mexico robert how can we help
how are you doing all well we're having
a blast what's going on
every day is a good day um i just had a
question i have uh you know where i work
now i make good money
and me and my wife are you know pretty
much get one up pretty much we're debt
free except for our mortgage okay and
uh the problem is is the company i'm
working for
basically
you know got rid of all the people that
started the company
and then now the new owner
is
wanting me
because i'm outside self wanting me to
do like things that i don't agree with
that to me
you know gouge them gouge our customers
and i don't agree with it okay so they
got rid of everyone else and those
people are starting a new company and
they want me to go there well i'm
leaving a
six bigger job to go there and then
start over
but i don't know if you know my wife
thinks it's a you know she doesn't know
if it's a good idea or not but morally i
can't
i just i can't do it right well so i'm
not into that but that's not because i'm
in construction
just to kind of give you a little yeah
well you're a good man robert you're a
good man and um
you've got a decision before you one way
or the other so you and your wife got to
sit down and go okay one way or the
other i can't keep doing this
i think the million-dollar question for
you robert is how much longer can you do
it are you at a point where you feel
like each
day that you stay here
and you're asked to do something you
don't agree with it's like could you
last 30 days doing this i don't think
the answer is yes but i want to know
what you how long can you last until you
find something else to step into if we
don't take this startup opportunity
oh i want to leave it today can you do
that financially
i have a lot of regular
customers that you know i'm charging
them double what i did before right and
it's just not right okay so they're just
making more money right so but
financially you can't walk today did i
hear you say that
yeah i mean
now i mean my wife makes good money too
so i think you could you don't have any
debt you don't have any debts we have
six months of our reserve yeah well i
don't want you to i don't want you to
necessarily use that my question is can
you live off of your wife's salary for
30 days 60 days
probably not okay so here's the deal
you're going to have to you got to be a
big boy you got to be grown up here and
so i think it comes down to doing your
homework and finding out what would you
make is it straight commission if you go
with the startup all these people you
used to work with
yes okay
so
you one way or the other it's like you
can't be without pay for 30 day well for
60. i think you could do 30 is what it
sounds like to me so you're gonna have
to bite your lip and you're not doing
anything unethical you may not like the
way it feels but until you can find
something to replace what you're doing
and you should be able to as good of a
salesman as you are you should be able
to do it or the other question is is how
quickly talk to these guys that want you
go hey let's be realistic guys
i i can't go 60 days without making
money how quickly am i going to be able
to get up and running and actually sell
some stuff have you had that
conversation
we've had that conversation but at the
same time i've already got
you know at least 10 to 15 customers
that said they'll go wherever i go oh
well you didn't tell me that that's
different okay i know absolutely i'm
getting into it okay no no no i'm not
getting on you i'm just going that's
again that's different information
um i'd go tomorrow if the 10 to 15 are
going to follow you i'd go tomorrow
because now you can sleep it well at
night you can live with yourself and
that's more than enough customers to get
you going
right
oh i absolutely yes well then it's a
no-brainer it's just my wife is not all
for it what would you how do you
convince
you know
you don't think you can get back to six
figures in no time
i think so well you got to show her that
robert this this is a safety issue your
wife doesn't feel safe
you've got to show her how you know i
know but listen but the good that's good
news and bad news bad news is your wife
doesn't feel safe the good news is all
you have to address is their safety so
you got to sit down with her with a good
old-fashioned piece of paper and pencil
and go with the 10 to 15 going with me
over here this is where i'm
realistically going to be in the first
three to six months it's going to pinch
us maybe a little bit but we're in no
way we're no way near any kind of danger
and you show her how long it's gonna
take to get where it's going and you
have a conversation where she goes oh
okay i feel safe and reminder we've got
six months in our emergency fund yeah we
have no consumer debt you're positioned
we can do this
you absolutely can do this
uh yeah i would do that tomorrow like
i'd do it today end of business
if i talk to my wife first i want the
wife to feel safe sorry smart man i did
get a little excited about how long
you've been married ken 23 years which
is why men did what i said there talk to
the wife then submit the resignation
that's the order of that